>> CHAIRMAN DURBIN, RANKING
MEMBER GRASSLEY AND
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR CONVENING THIS
HEARING AND FOR CONSIDERING MY
NOMINATION AS ASSOCIATE JUSTICE
OF THE SUPREME COURT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
I AM HUMBLED AND HONORED TO BE
HERE.
I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE
INTRODUCTIONS THAT MY FORMER
JUDICIAL COLLEAGUE, JUDGE TOM
GRIFFITH AND MY CLOSE FRIEND,
PROFESSOR LISA FAIRFAX HAVE SO
GRACIOUSLY PROVIDED.
I'M ALSO VERY THANKFUL FOR THE
CONFIDENCE THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
HAS PLACED IN ME AND FOR THE
KIND NESS THAT HE AND FIRST LAD
AND THE VICE PRESIDENT AND THE
SECOND GENTLEMAN HAS EXTENDED TO
ME AND MY FAMILY.
TODAY WILL BE THE FOURTH TIME
THAT I'VE HAD THE HONOR OF
APPEARING BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
TO BE CONSIDERED FOR
CONFIRMATION.
OVER THE PAST THREE WEEK, I HAVE
ALSO HAD THE HONOR OF MEETING
EACH MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE
SEPARATELY.
I'VE MET WITH 45 SENATORS IN
TOTAL.
YOUR CAREFUL ATTENTION TO MY
NOMINATION DEMONSTRATES YOUR
DEDICATION TO THE CRUCIAL ROLE
THAT THE SENATE PLAYS IN THIS
CONSTITUTIONAL PROCESS AND I
THANK YOU.
WHILE I'M ON THE SUBJECT OF
GRATITUDE, I MUST ALSO PAUSE TO
REAFFIRM MY THANKS TO GOD FOR IT
IS FAITH THAT SUSTAINS ME AT
THIS MOMENT.
EVEN PRIOR TO TODAY, I CAN
HONESTLY SAY THAT MY LIFE HAS
BEEN BLESSED BEYOND MEASURE.
THE FIRST OF MY MANY BLESSINGS
IS THE FACT I WAS BORN IN THIS
GREAT NATION.
A LITTLE OVER 50 YEARS AGO IN
SEPTEMBER OF 1970.
CONGRESS ENBASENACTED TWO CIVIL
RIGHTS ACTS THE DECADE BEFORE
AND SO MANY EXPERIENCED LAWFUL
RACIAL SEGREGATION FIRST HAND,
MY PARENTS LEFT THEIR HOMETOWN
OF MIAMI, FLORIDA AND MOVED TO
WA
WASHINGTON, D.C. TO EXPERIENCE
NEW FREEDOM.
WHEN I WAS BORN HERE, MY PARENTS
WERE PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHERS AND
TO EXPRESS PRIDE FROM THEIR
HERITAGE AND HOPE FOR THE
FUTURE, THEY GAVE ME AN AFRICAN
NAME.
KETANJ WHICH THEY WERE TOLD
MEANS LUCKY ONE.
LIKE THE MANY BARRIERS THEY HAD
TO FACE GROWING UP, MY PATH WAS
CLEARER SO IF I WORKED HARD AND
I BELIEVED IN MYSELF IN AMERICA,
I COULD DO ANYTHING OR BE
ANYTHING I WANTED TO BE.
LIKE SO MANY FAMILIES IN THE
COUNTRY THEY WORKED LONG HOURS
AND SACRIFICED TO PROVIDE THEIR
CHILDREN EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO
REACH THEIR GOD GIVEN POTENTIAL.
MY PARENTS HAVE BEEN MARRIED
ALMOST 54 YEARS AND THEY ARE
HERE WITH ME TODAY.
I CANNOT POSSIBLY THANK THEM
ENOUGH FOR EVERYTHING THEY HAVE
DONE FOR ME.
I LOVE YOU, MOM AND DAD.
MY FATHER BEARS INTEREST IN THE
LAW.
WHEN I WAS FOUR, WE MOVED BACK
TO MIAMI SO HE COULD BE A LAW
STUDENT.
WE LIVED OEN THE CAMPUS OF THE
LAW SCHOOL.
MY MOTHER PULLED DOUBLE DUTY
WORKING AS THE SOLE BREADWINNER
WHILE GUIDING AND INSPIRING
4-YEAR-OLD ME.
MY VERY EARLIEST MEMORIES ARE OF
WATCHING MY FATHER STUDY.
HE HAD HIS STACK OF LAW BOOK ONS
THE KITCHEN TABLE WHILE I SAT
ACROSS FROM HIM WITH HI STACK OF
COLORING BOOKS.
HI PARENTS ALSO INSTILLED IN ME
AND MY YOUNGER BROTHER, KETAJ,
THE IMPORTANCE OF PUBLIC
SERVICE.
AFTER GRADUATING FROM HOWARD
UNIVERSITY, KETAJ STARTED OFF AS
A POLICE OFFICER FOLLOWING TWO
OF OUR UNCLES.
AFTER THE SEPTEMBER 11th ATTACK
ON OUR COUNTRY, HE VOLUNTEER FOR
THE ARMY AND BECAME AN INFANTRY
OFFICER SEMRVING TWO TOURS OF
DUTY.
HE IS HERE TODAY PROVIDING HIS
LOVE AND SUPPORT AS ALWAYS.
SPEAKING OF UNCONDITIONAL LOVE,
I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE YOU TO
MY HUSBAND OF 25 YEARS,
DR. PATRICK JACKSON.
I HAVE NO DOUBT THAT WITHOUT HIM
BY MY SIDE FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING OF THIS INCREDIBLE,
PROFESSAL JOURNEY, NONE OF THIS
WOULD HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE.
WE MET IN COLLEGE MORE THAN
THREE DECADES AGO AND SINCE
THEN, HE'S BEEN THE BEST
HUSBAND, FATHER AND FRIEND I
COULD EVER IMAGINE.
PATRICK, I LOVE YOU.
WILLIAM, PATRICK'S IDENTICAL
TWIN BROTHER IS HERE AWELL ALONG
WITH HIS WIFE.
ALSO IS HIS OLDER BROTHER AND
HIS WIFE NATALIE.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST, MY DEAR
INLAWS.
PAMELA AND GARDENER JACKSON HAVE
TRAVELED HERE FROM BOSTON TO BE
WITH ME TODAY.
I'VE SAVING A SPECIAL
INTRODUCTION FOR MY DAUGHTERS.
GIRLS, I KNOW IT'S NOT BEEN EASY
AS I'VE TRIED TO NAVIGATE THE
CHALLENGES OF JUGGLING MY CAREER
AND MOTHERHOOD.
I FULLY ADMIT THAT I DID NOT
ALWAYS GET THE BALANCE RIGHT.
I HOPE YOU HAVE SEEN WITH HARD
WORK, DETERMINATION AND LOVE, IT
CAN BE DONE.
I'M SO LOOKING FORWARD TO WHAT
YOU CHOOSE TO DO.
I LOVE YOU SO MUCH.
THERE'S SO MANY WHO HAVE NOT
HERE TODAY BUT WHOM I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE.
I HAVE A LARGE EXTENDED FAMILY
ON BOTH SIDES.
THEY ARE WATCHING FROM FLORIDA,
NORTH CAROLINA, NEW JERSEY,
CONNECTICUT, NEW YORK,
MASSACHUSETTS, COLORADO AND
BEYOND.
I ALSO HAVE INCREDIBLE FRIENDS.
THREE OF MY COLLEGE ROOMMATES
CAME HERE TO SUPPORT ME.
I HAVE SO MANY BOOSTERS, HARVARD
UNDERGRAD, HARVARD LAW SCHOOL
AND THROUGHOUT MY PERSONAL,
PROFESSAL LIFE
.
SHE BELIEVED IN ME AND IN TURN,
I BELIEVED IN MYSELF.
IT WAS MY GREAT GOOD FORTUNE TO
HAVE THE CHANCE TO CHLORLERK FO
THREE BRILLIANT JURISTS.
THESE EXTRAORDINARY PEOPLE WERE
EXCEPTIONAL ROLE MODELS.
JUSTICE BREYER NOT ONLY GAVE ME
THE GREATEST JOB THAT ANY YOUNG
LAWYER COULD HOPE TO HAVE BUT HE
EXEMPLIFIES WHAT IT MEANS TO BE
A SUPREME COURT JUSTICE OF THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF SKILL AND
INTEGRITY, CIVILITY AND GRACE.
IT'S HUMBLING TO BE CONSIDERED
FOR JUSTICE BREYER'S SEAT AND
YI
KNOW I COULD NEVER FILL HIS
SHOES.
IF CONFIRMED, I WOULD HOPE TO
CARRY ON HIS SPIRIT.
ON THE DAY OF HIS SUPREME COURT
NOMINATION, JUSTICE BREYER SAID
WHAT IS LAW SUPPOSED TO DO SEEN
AS A WHOLE?
IT IS SUPPOSED TO ALLOW ALL
PEOPLE, AUM PEOPLE TO LIVE
TOGETHER IN A SOCIETY WHERE THEY
HAVE SO MANY DIFFERENT VIEWS, SO
MANY DIFFERENT NEEDS TO LIVE
TOGETHER IN A WAY THAT IS MORE
HARMONIOUS, THAT IS BETTER SO
THEY CAN WORK PRODUCTIVELY
TOGETHER.
END QUOTE.
I COULD NOT HAVE SAID IT BETTER
MYSELF.
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE, IF I
AM CONFIRMED, I COMMIT TO YOU
THAT I WILL WORK PRODUCTIVELY TO
SUPPORT AND DEFEND THE
CONSTITUTION AND THIS GRAND
EXPERIMENT OF AMERICAN DEMOCRACY
THAT HAS ENDURED OVER THESE PAST
246 YEARS.
I HAVE BEEN A JUDGE FOR NEARLY A
DECADE NOW AND I TAKE THAT
RESPONSIBILITY AND MY DUTY TO BE
INDEPENDENT VERY SERIOUSLY.
I DECIDE CASES FROM A NEUTRAL
POSTURE.
I EVALUATE THE FACTS AND I
INTERPRET AND APPLY THE LAW TO
THE FACTS OF THE CASE BEFORE ME
WITHOUT FEAR OR FAVOR,
CONSISTENT WITH MY JUDICIAL
OATH.
I KNOW THAT MY ROLE AS A JUDGE
IS A LIMITED ONE.
THAT THE CONSTITUTION EMPOWERS
ME ONLY TO DECIDE CASES AND
TR
CONTROVERSIES THAT ARE PROPERLY
PRESENTED.
I KNOW MY JUDICIAL ROLE IS
FURTHER CONSTRAINED BY CAREFUL
ADHERENCE TO PRECEDENT.
YOU MAY HAVE READ SOME OF MY
MORE THAN A 570 DECISIONS AND
THEY TEND TO BE ON THE LONG
SIDE.
THAT'S BECAUSE I BELIEVE IN
TRANSPARENCY.
PEOPLE SHOULD KNOW PRECISELY
WHAT I THINK AND THE BASIS FOR
MY DECISION.
ALL OF MY PROFESSIONAL
EXPERIENCES INCLUDING MY WORK AS
PUBLIC DEFENDER AND AS A TRIAL
JUDGE HAVE INSTILLED IN ME THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING EACH
LITIGANT KNOW THAT THE JUDGE IN
THEIR CASE HAS HEARD THEM
WHETHER OR NOT THEIR ARGUMENTS
PREVAIL IN COURT.
DURING THIS HEARING, I HOPE THAT
YOU WILL SEE HOW MUCH I LOVE OUR
COUNTRY AND THE CONSTITUTION AND
THE RIGHTS THAT MAKE US FREE.
I STAND ON THE SHOULDERS OF SO
MANY WHO HAVE COME BEFORE ME,
INCLUDING JUDGE CONSTANCE BAKER
MOTTELEY WHO WAS THE FIRST
AFRICAN-AMERICAN WOMAN TO BE
APPOINTED TO THE FEDERAL BENCH
AND WITH WHOM I SHARE A
BIRTHDAY.
LIKE JUDGE MOTTLEY, I HAVE
DEDICATED MY CAREER TO ENSURING
THE WORDS ENGRAVED ON THE FRONT
OF THE SUPREME COURT BUILDING
EQUAL JUSTICE LAW ARE A REALITY
AND NOT JUST AN IDEAL.
TH
THANK YOU FOR THIS HISTORIC
CHANCE TO JOIN THE HIGHEST
COURT, TO WORK WITH BRILLIANT
COLLEAGUES, TO INSPIRE FUT